time now for a final guess and there
were yet more allegations of misconduct
in Westminster this week from a
conservative MP losing the whip
following a complaint made to police the
claims of sleaze around the awarding of
PPE contracts during the pandemic it all
adds up to a constant drip drip of
stories ranging from bullying and
harassment to rule breaking and serious
sexual misconduct in recent years so is
there a particular problem in
Westminster politics and what is going
wrong well one person who might have a
view Sonya Khan who was a special
advisor to not one but two conservative
chancellors and Philip Hammond and Sajid
Java she settled an unfair dismissal
claim having been marched out of Downing
Street and has spoken of the environment
of bullying and bad behavior very good
to talk to you today Sonia
um are you surprised by what seems to be
a constant stream of these kind of
allegations and cases that are still
coming out
um I'm not surprised I think that over
the last few years we have created
um a system where actually if people
feel much more empowered to take action
I mean it's not perfect but I think
um what we have is a Westminster that
hasn't really changed but we have um a
group of people now
um that can work together or have seen
um examples of other people who've taken
action and feel comfortable to be able
to say actually this behavior is not
okay this isn't acceptable I feel like
there is much more of a standard now
about what good and bad behavior looks
like um in Westminster whereas I don't
think that quite existed before but we
have had a number of inquiries you know
Dame Laura Cox inquiry 2018
um 2020 to Alexander Allen's report and
to put into pretty Patel now there's
some inquiring to Dominic Robb do you
think that they actually change anything
do you think they're worth the paper
they're written on
um it's I mean it's difficult to say
because in my circumstance I had to um
take legal action in order to to change
behaviors or to get people to look at
what actually went wrong which isn't the
ideal solution because it's quite a
costly process
um I mean I think in truth we have a
system where the only change that
happens is when it comes to general
elections so I guess you could say
there's a way for constituents to change
who their MPS if they think that
actually the story is about bullying are
right but if you're a victim of bullying
whether you're in the civil service or
whether you're someone who works in
Westminster or quite a junior role you
work in Parliament then there isn't
really a way to change things other than
you changing so often that means people
have to leave their job or they leave
the sector or they go do something
completely different I've known people
who've become doctors or have gone to
work for Charities because I don't like
the culture of of Westminster so you I
guess there are elements that can be
changed but for most people the the way
that change happens is they have to
change the role themselves and we've
seen of course a number of politicians
male and female saying that they're not
going to stand again in in this current
election but quite a lot of them
relatively young female MPS do you think
political culture could have played a
part in that
I do and I think that the scrutiny that
many female MPS have is far greater than
male MPS who've seen people's romantic
lives uh being dissected uh in
newspapers we've seen some of their sort
of fashion choices dissected and I feel
like for a lot of them it must come to
the point where they decide that they
don't want that anymore
um so I can totally understand that and
I can also see why politics perhaps
doesn't always feel very rewarding in
this current environment and how maybe
they can affect change in perhaps
slightly different roles
there will be some though that will say
look you know politics like lots of jobs
is a high pressure environment there are
going to be big egos there are going to
be long hours people are going to be
exhausted strong personalities it's all
part of the job if you want to work in
that environment you just have to
toughen up a bit
um there is that sense and I would argue
you can have that in so many careers you
can have that in law you can have that
in medicine but the biggest difference
between those careers and politics is
that it isn't meritocratic so you can be
the smartest person you could have
dedicated your life to public service
for 40 or 50 years but that's not
necessarily what's going to help you
succeed it's a very very reputation
heavy and I think that's where the
frustration can come from from a lot of
people so it's much more about do you
know the right person are you in favor
with the right person or do your actions
sort of work for the current government
um and and I can see why that element of
the job perhaps isn't very attractive
and I think that's perhaps the
distinction to meet between other
careers that you can succeed just by
working hard whereas in politics there's
a bit more of a game to be played
so it seems that you're suggesting it's
riddled with cronyism
I mean I think that
the prize to anyone
as well it's very much based on kind of
who you know rather than than what you
know I mean you do need a base level of
um probably intelligence to be able to
get on especially with scrutiny that
comes through select committees and
whatever but yeah primarily it's oh have
you voted the right way do you know the
right people
so it's it's a you know rather than what
you know there is still no independent
advisor on ethics Liz truss said that
you know she knew what ethics were and
she didn't need one do you think that
that there should be somebody in place
in that role and soon
I don't think that an advisor on ethics
is going to fix the system that we have
I think it's much more structural than
that
um I think I've said before that there
are always people at the bottom in
politics and I don't think you can
change that but you do need to look at
how do you create a system that
encourages those people to speak up and
and does in a way that makes them feel
very protected so I'm talking about you
know lots of the Pas secretaries kind of
the people who bear the brunt of bad
behavior often
um and I feel like sometimes these roles
only focus or engage with the very very
seniors so how much having an
independent advisor will help perhaps
those who are going to struggle the most
I I don't know I feel like there's a
much more sort of wholesale change that
needs to happen but it needs to be
bottom up and and you yourself have
moved on you've got a new career uh
you've got a a new baby if you've known
how bad it would be and and looking back
would you have done it would you have
would you have still done gone the route
you've gone
um it's it's a good question I mean I do
have a baby and I'm not sure I would
want my sons to take the same path but
at the same time um I feel really proud
to have achieved change whether it's
change for women or period poverty or
whether it's trying to just represent a
different class of people
um to senior people like Prime Ministers
and chancellors so I guess that's a half
answer I'm grateful for what for what I
was able to do but perhaps right now I
wouldn't be encouraging a small child
into politics and this
um there is a major change about how
people are supported
case and you can't it's been lovely to
talk to you thanks a lot former special
advisors Sajid Javid and Philip Hammond
thank you